merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame sénatrice
Gatel donc pour redire et et le redire à
Monsieur le Maire il y a tous les maires
qui font l'objet de violence faite aux
élus ces dernières semaines mais j'ai
envie de vous dire tout à fait en
introduction que le diagnostic nous le
partageons que c'est par l'écoute c'est
par la proximité c'est par le respect
les uns des autres c'est par la
solidarité mais aussi c'est par l'action
je vous le redis monsieur le sénateur
que l'on va pouvoir endiguer cette
violence faite aux élus alors vous
parlez de la du couple préfet mère on le
connaît tous ici il est efficace il est
à l'action alors bien sûr nous allons
écouter Monsieur le Maire et nous allons
écouter je l'écouterai aux côtés de
madame la Première ministre les raisons
qui lui font percevoir que effectivement
les services de l'État n'ont pas été à
la hauteur de vos attentes et on va vous
écouter et ça dans l'esprit de ce qu'a
dit Christophe Béchu tout à l'heure de
toujours s'améliorer oui on va
s'améliorer de ce que vous allez nous
dire Monsieur le Maire et de votre
perception de cette inaction perçue par
vous moi je veux pas rappeler ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure on a le
sentiment d'avoir agi cependant on est
vraiment à l'écoute et avec une envie
cheville au corps d'avancer alors vous
me demandez de dévoiler quelques actions
et seulement il s'agit ici de vous le
dire en deux minutes donc c'est un peu
court me semble-t-il mais je voudrais
juste citer un point un point
ça s'appelle l'alarme élu c'est 3000
référents dans la gendarmerie et dans la
police nationale qui seront dès le début
de la semaine prochaine investis de une
extrême proximité ce sera des référents
violents aux élus ça a été décidé par le
début de la semaine par Gérald Darmanin
et c'est ce qui va faire juste si vous
voulez bien m'écouter une seconde c'est
super important j'ai plus que 10
secondes alarme élu ça veut dire qu'il
faut que vous invitiez les maires à
donner leur numéro de téléphone au
préfet au gendarmes ou à la police pour
que quand ils appelleront écoutez-moi
pour que
pour que quand ils appelleront ils
puissent bénéficier d'un traitement
spécifique messieurs et mesdames les
sénateurs je vous en dirai plus un peu
plus tard merci à vous
[Musique]